THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA OUR QUE
HAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM BURNER **** BATH
[inaudible]
BONTA BRO.
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU CHOI.
KANSEN CHU COOLEY.
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY.
DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LOW MOAN.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH.
STONE [inaudible]
TEEN VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER.
WICKS WOOD MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN.
REVEREND PATTY OSHA.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
AS I REFLECTED ON THE BOUNDLESS
NATURE OF A MOTHER'S LOVE.
ARE WE CALLED AN INCIDENT SHARED
BY NISSI SOLDIER SERVING IN THE
U. S. ARMY IN OCCUPIED JAPAN.
ONE IS THE FIRST LEAVE HERE
RANGE TO VISIT THE VILLAGE WHERE
HIS PARENTS WERE RAISED.
FROM THE P. X. HE PURCHASED
BOXES OF HERSHEY'S CHOCOLATE
BARS TO SHARE WITH FAMILY HE
WOULD BE MEETING FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
HE WEARS WELCOME SO WARMLY AND
HIS GIFT OF CHOCOLATE BARS.
WAS RECEIVED SO GRACEFULLY.
HE WAS TOLD THAT THROUGHOUT THE
WAR FOOD WAS SCARCE AND TO HAVE
CHOCOLATE CANDY WAS A TREAT
BEYOND CONSIDERATION.
THEY HAVE NOT TASTED CHOCOLATE
IN YEARS.
HE WAS PLEASED TO SEE THEM SO
ENJOYING HIS GIFT.
THEN HE NOTICED ONE RELATIVE A
YOUNG MOTHER HOLDING HER ON OPEN
CHOCOLATE BAR.
HE ENCOURAGED HER TO TRY IT.
PROMISING THAT HE WOULD BRING
MORE NEXT TIME.
SHE SMALL GRACEFULLY AND SAID.
THIS WONDERFUL TREAT IS EVEN
MORE DELICIOUS IN THE MOUTH OF
MY CHILD.
IT WAS THEN THE SOLDIER NOTICE
THE YOUNG CHILD NEXT TO THE
MOTHER.
EYES CLOSED WITH CHOCOLATE
FINGERS FEEDING A CHOCOLATE
SMILE.
THIS SUNDAY LET US TAKE THE TIME
TO APPRECIATE OUR MOTHERS WE
HAVE ALWAYS LOVED THIS MORE THAN
CHOCOLATE.
AND WILL ALWAYS LOVE US MORE
THAN LIFE ITSELF.
LET US REMEMBER THAT OUR
HAPPINESS WILL ALWAYS ALSO BE
THEIR HAPPINESS.
AND WE CAN ONLY WE PAY THEM BY
LIVING HAPPILY AND FULFILLED.
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
LOST OUR MOMS.
NO THIS IS STILL BIRTHDAY.
THAT S. APPRECIATE THEM.
AND HOLD THEM ALWAYS CLOSE TO
OUR HEARTS.
NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER TWO THE
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND OUR STAFF WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING IN TO JOIN US
FOR THE FLAG SALUTE.
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE PLACE RIGHT OVER
YOUR HEART READY AGAIN.
STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY
NINETEEN RECENTLY MET AT SEVEN
AM MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND
MISS WALDRON SECONDS THAT THE
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE
.
TODAY'S ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA. TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY TODAY WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
ALSO AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR IS PLEASE REMOVE THE
FOLLOWING BILL FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR I DON'T WANT ANY FOR AB
TWENTY FIVE CHAO ITEM ONE NINETY
AB. SEVENTEEN SIXTY THREE TWO
ITEM TWO TWENTY ONE AB THIRTEEN
NINETY SIX OBERNOLTE AND AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
NUMBER.
TWO HUNDRED AB FIVE SIXTEEN BY
DAVID CHIU.
THE CLERK WILL NOT.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE THE ASSEMBLY SECOND READING
THE CLERK WILL READ.
A SOME ABLE 1-665-168-1650 NINE
SIX NINETY SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
240-124-02390 ONE FOUR OF
754-075-6711 840-610-1811.
FORTY SIX ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE
ALTHOUGH 912-261-26612
911-308-1320 FOUR FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AT 215-641-62817.
471-768-1780 218-052-54340
944-065-9720 877-984-0890
294-099-5710 261-072-1130
211-611-16411 661-168-1190
912-781-29012 991-311-1350
213-701-37613 791-484-1490.
715-351-56115 731-666-1709
EIGHTEEN OH TWO EIGHTEEN TEN
EIGHTEEN THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN
FIFTEEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN AND
EIGHTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ALL BILLS
HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
MISTER CALDERON FOR WHAT PURPOSE
DRESS -- FOR MOTION.
QUE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM
TEN SEVENTY TWO PATTERSON FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE CLERK
WILL NOT.
MOVING TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING.
FILE ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT AB FOR
THIRTY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER RAMOS AND
ACTUALLY TO PROBATION.
MISTER RAMOS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THE MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB FOR THIRTY THREE THIS
BILL PROVIDES A TWO DAY
NOTIFICATION TO THE VICTIMS WHEN --
PROBATION IS TERMINATED EARLY.
IN CASES WHERE.
RESTITUTION HAS ALREADY BEEN
GRANTED.
IT'S EARLY TERMINATION OF
PROBATION AND NOTIFICATION TO
THE VICTIM NEEDS TO BE NEEDS TO
BE DONE.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION MR OMINOUS AB FOR
THIRTY THREE INSURERS THE
VICTIMS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SEEK THE RESTITUTION THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN PROMISED TO THEM.
THROUGH THE DISH JUDICIAL
PROCESS IN A TITLE TO THEM UNDER
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CONSTITUTION.
THIS BILL IS A COMMONSENSE
ADJUSTMENT TO EXISTING LAW TO
ENSURE WE DO RIGHT BY THE
VICTIMS OF CRIME GIVING THEM A
VOICE IN THESE PROCEEDINGS.
THANK YOU MISTER RAMOS MR
GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I
ALSO RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FOR THIRTY THREE THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE ADJUSTMENT TO
EXISTING LAW THAT WILL ENSURE
THAT THOSE WHO HAVE FACED
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
FROM VICTIMIZATION ARE NOT LEFT
BEHIND IN THE LEGAL PROCESS
VICTIMS DESERVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ARGUE FOR THE RESTITUTION
THEY HAVE BEEN PROMISED AND
THEIR JUDICIAL PROCESS.
AND THIS BILL PROVIDES THEM
ADEQUATE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO I
THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM HIGHLAND
FOR HIS WORK ON THIS ISSUE AND I
ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAYSON SEE.
DOCTOR QUIRK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU --
THERE'S ALWAYS TO STE THANK YOU
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS THERE'S%
ALWAYSTWO SIDES TO THIS YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT BOTH THE
PROTECTION OF THE PEOPLE WHO.
NEED TO BE NOTIFIED BUT YOU ALSO
HAVE TO MAKE SURE.
THAT YOU PROTECT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE BEING -- CONVICTED AND MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE I THINK THIS
JUST -- STRIKES THE RIGHT
BALANCE PROTECTION OF ON ALL
SIDES AND THAT'S WHY SUPPORTED
IN PUBLIC SAFETY.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER MISTER ON US TO MAKE
US THANK YOU IN A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THANK YOU.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO START OF IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED OF A
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY THREE
NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS SEVENTY NINE THREE
EIGHTY THREE WILL BE PASSED THE
RETAINS.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTY FOUR A. B. FIFTEEN OH
SEVEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH.
FAMILY MEMBERS WITH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I AM PRESENTING AB
FIFTEEN OH SEVEN FOR THE PURPOSE
OF AMENDMENTS.
THESE AMENDMENTS ARE THE PRODUCT
OF ONGOING CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION.
AMENDMENTS WILL ALLOW FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND RESOURCE
CENTERS TO BE CITED OUTSIDE OF
THEIR AUTHORIZING DISTRICT UNDER
THE FOLLOWING CIRCUMSTANCES. ONE
IF THERE'S A PRESIDENTIAL
DECLARATION OF EMERGENCY OR IF
THE CHARTER SCHOOL OR RESOURCE
CENTER WAS APPROVED BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
WHICH GRANDFATHERS ALL EXISTING
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND THEIR
RESOURCE CENTERS.
THROUGH THEIR RENEWAL DATE
AMENDMENTS ALSO ALLOW FOR
PROCESS FOR AGREEMENTS FOR
CONTINUED OPERATION UPON THAT RE
AUTHORIZATION.
THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THE AMENDMENT.
ALL IN FAVOR I AM.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AMENDMENTS ADOPTED.
BILL IS OUT OF PRINT AND BACK TO
FILE.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE WILL BE
PASSED TO RETAIN MOVING TO FILE
ITEM EIGHTY SEVEN AB SIXTY NO TO
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NO TO BUY
SOMETHING NUMBER LOW ACTUALLY TO
INSURANCE.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
SIXTY NO TO A PROHIBIT INSURANCE
PRODUCT THAT SOME CALL MURDER
INSURANCE.
FROM BEING SOLD IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
NATIONAL RIFLE ASSOCIATION
STARTED SELLING THIS INSURANCE
POLICY CALLED KERRY GUARD WHICH
COVERS CRIMINAL AND CIVIL
DEFENSE IS FOR GUN OWNERS.
WHO YEARS THEIR GUNS IN A
SHOOTING -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE IN HOLDING OUR
COMMUNITY ACCOUNTABLE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE --
MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED OF A
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO THE
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE.
TWELVE THIS MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM MOVING TO VIOLATE IN
EIGHTY SIX AB THREE OH NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL THREE OH NINE WITH
THE MEMONS BASED ON THE NUMBER
MAIENSCHEIN.
MR MANSION MAIENSCHEIN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB THREE
OH NINE PERMITS FEDERAL STATE
AND LOCAL HISTORICAL SOCIETIES
IN MUSEUMS TO DISPLAY A POLICE
VEHICLES MADE AFTER NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE FOR ME MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS CLARIFY THESE.
CANNOT BE DRIVEN ON THE ROAD AND
LESS TRAVELING TO OR FOR OUR
FROM AN EXHIBITOR DISPLAY
LOCATION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAIENSCHEIN.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE.
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED.
BILL IS OUT TO PRINT IN BACK TO
FILE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY AB FOR THIRTEEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR THIRTEEN BY
SOME MEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DO YOUTH.
MR JOHNSON WHERE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER A. B.
FOR THIRTEEN CHANGES REFERENCES
OF AT RISK TO AT PROMISE.
IN EDUCATION AND PENAL CODE OF
FOR YOU YOU MAY RECOGNIZE HIS
BILL AS AN EXTENSION OF LAST
YEAR'S ACR ONE NINETY SEVEN
WHICH IDENTIFIED IMPORTANCE OF
AT PROMISE.
AT RECEIVES A STIGMATIZED LABEL
THAT CREATES AN EXPECTATION OF
FAILURE AND FOCUS ON THE
LIKELIHOOD OF USE BECOMING
ANOTHER STATISTIC.
THIS IS THE MINDSET THAT IS ALL
TO PURSUE PERVASIVE IN OUR
SCHOOLS COMMUNITIES AND JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
BY PERCEPTION MATTERS AND OUR
YOUTH ARE MORE THAN THEIR
SITUATION LET'S BE INTENTIONAL
WITH OUR WORDS AND EMPOWER
STUDENTS IN THE SAME WAY WE
RESPECT PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
BY USING PEOPLE FIRST LANGUAGE.
AB FOR THIRTEEN TRANSITIONS
CALIFORNIA TO THE STRENGTH BATES
APPROACH OF AB PROMISING
RECOGNIZES THE POTENTIAL OF
EVERY USED TO SUCCEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
MISTER MATHIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOR THIRTEEN I KNOW WE CAN GET
VERY SENTIMENTAL ON THE USE OF
WORDS AND SOME OF US MIGHT THINK.
THIS MEASURE DOESN'T ACTUALLY
REALLY DO ANYTHING [inaudible]
BUT WHEN WE LOOK AT OUR YOUTH
SUICIDE RATES AND HOW THEY'RE
SKYROCKETING.
THAT SIMPLE CONVERSATION OF HEY
WE PROMISED TO DO OUR BEST TO
HELP YOU OUT.
VERSES HEY YOUR ROUTE RISKING
YOUR MESSING UP.
THAT SIMPLE CONVERSATION COULD
CHANGE THE LIFE OR DEATH OF OUR
KIDS THAT ARE THINKING ABOUT
SUICIDE I THINK THIS WILL
ACTUALLY HELP LOWER THOSE
SUICIDE RATES OF MEMBERS I ASK
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER MATH.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISTER
JONES ARE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU NICE AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ACROSS OUT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRED OF
A ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED
OF A THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES
FIFTY ONE KNOWS. ONE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY ONE
AB THREE THIRTY THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL THREE THIRTY WITH
AMENDMENTS BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GABRIEL.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT
AMENDMENTS TO AB THREE THIRTY
THESE AMENDMENTS OUT CO AUTHORS
AND MAKE MINOR TECHNICAL CHANGES
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS.
ON THESE AMENDMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ON
FAVOR AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED THE
BILL IS OUT TO FILING BACK TO
PRINCE.
WE TO FILE ITEM NINETY THREE AB
SIX THIRTY FOR THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX THIRTY FOUR BY
SOMETHING NUMBER SALAS AN
ACTUALLY THE HIGHWAYS.
MR SALAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS BACK IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN THE LEGISLATURE PASSED
CHAPTER FIVE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
ALLOW THE NAMING OF HIGHWAY
BRIDGES.
THIS MEASURE ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
THIRTY FOUR SIMPLY AS ROUND
ABOUT SO THAT WE CAN THAT NAME
THEM PROPERLY.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THIS IS SOMETHING WE DO FOR
FALLEN VETERANS FOLLOWING PUBLIC
SAFETY OFFICERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU MISTER SALAS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK.
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED OF A
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY THREE NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING.
TO FILE ITEMS NINETY FOUR NINETY
FIVE AND NINETY TWO WE PASSED
RETAIN MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETY SIX AB.
TWELVE SIXTY ONE THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY ONE
BY SOMEONE MEMBER JONES SAWYER
AND ACTUALLY TO CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCES.
MR JOHNSON WHERE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWELVE SIXTY
ONE A BILL THAT DID LEASE
REQUIREMENT FOR NARCOTICS
OFFICERS TO RISK REGISTER WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW A PERSON
CONVICTED OF CERTAIN DRUG
OFFENSES IS REQUIRED TO REGISTER
WITH THE LOCAL POLICE CHIEF OR
SHERIFF.
WERE REGISTERING INDIVIDUALS IS
REQUIRED TO PROVIDE FINGERPRINTS
GET PHOTOGRAPH AND PROVIDE
INFORMATION SUCH AS THEIR
ADDRESS DATE OF BIRTH DRIVER'S
LICENSE AN OCCUPATION ADDRESS
AND VEHICLE INFORMATION.
THIS IS AN INEFFICIENT PROCESS
AND REDUNDANT GIVEN THAT ALL OF
THIS INFORMATION PROVIDED IN A
REGISTRY CAN BE FOUND IN A
PERSON'S CRIMINAL RECORD.
AB TWELVE SIXTY ONE WOULD DELETE
THE REQUIREMENT OF NARCOTICS
OFFICER TO REGISTER WITH LOCAL.
LAW ARE NOT BECAUSE OFFENDERS TO
REGISTER WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COURTS
INVALUABLE TIME AND RESOURCES
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED TO THEIR TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NINETY SEVEN
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
A SOME PEOPLE FOURTEEN TWENTY
THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS
ACTUALLY TO DO THE NILES.
MISS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW ONCE A
DECISION IS MADE TO TRANSFER A
JUVENILE TO ADULT COURT THEY MAY
NOT BE TRANSFERRED BACK TO THE
JUVENILE SYSTEM.
THIS IS PATENTLY UNFAIR
SITUATION WHAT MY ABILITY WILL
BASICALLY GIVE -- CRATER PROCESS
TO GIVE THE JUDGE MORE
DISCRETION TO MOVE JUVENILES
BACK TO THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IF THAT CASE IS THE TERM
TO BE LESS SEVERE -- WE THINK
IT'S A AN IMPORTANT AND A SIMPLE
FIX -- THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME
EQUITY HERE WITHIN THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM WE'VE GOT THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
SUPPORTING THIS BUILDING AND TO
RECIDIVISM COALITION THE ELLA
BAKER CENTER.
I AND MANY OTHER GREAT
ORGANIZATIONS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU REST WHERE X. SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED OF A
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTERS ART OF A
MISS REX WILL MOVE THE CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL
READ
ASSEMBLY WILL TELL THIRTEEN BY
SOME REMEMBER TING AND ACTING A
LOT FIRST MEANT.
MR TING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWELVE FIFTEEN THE
BIPARTISAN BILL.
THAT WOULD BAN LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES AND OFFICIALS FROM
USING INSTALLING OR ACTIVATING
FACIAL RECOGNITION AND BIOMETRIC
SCANNERS IN BODY CAMERAS.
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE -- NOW HAD
BODY CAMERA TECHNOLOGY BEING
USED BY MOST LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES IN THE STATE.
WE DO WANT INSURANCE PRECAUTION
THAT WE ARE NOT INSTALLING THE
FACIAL RECOGNITION SOFTWARE.
AT THAT POINT AT THIS POINT IT
IS CURRENTLY FLAWS OF MUCH OF IT
IS -- BEING USED THAT IS THE
MUCH OF IT IS -- THAT IS BEING
USE RIGHT NOW IS ACTUALLY NOT
VERY ACCURATE I JUST TO GIVE AN
EXAMPLE AMAZON'S RECOGNITION
SYSTEM FALSELY IDENTIFY.
TWENTY EIGHT SITTING MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS AS PEOPLE IN A MUGSHOT
DATABASE.
WITH MEMBERS OF COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEING
MISIDENTIFIED.
I AB TWELVE FIFTEEN SEEKS TO
PREVENT FURTHER MISTRUST BETWEEN
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T USE THIS FACIAL
THIS FLAWED FACIAL RECOGNITION
SOFTWARE.
THANK YOU MISTER TING MISTER
CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU SPEAKER AND A MEMBERS --
I RISE.
TODAY IN OPPOSITION OFF A A. B.
[inaudible]
TWELVE FIFTEEN COLLEAGUES SAW.
WE CAN ALL SHARE IN THE CONCERN
SO OVER THE PRIVACY OF WHAT
INDIVIDUALS.
NO PROBLEM LAND STAR IN THE
NATURE THAT THE INDIVIDUALS YOU
AND ME. FOR GORE OUR PRIVACY
WHEN WE ENTER A PUBLIC SPACES.
THE USE OF A BIOMETRIC SO BY LAW
AND ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ARE NOT
ONLY PLACES SAW A WAR.
AGENCIES -- IN A MORE PRIVATE
[inaudible]
PROACTIVE STANCE IN FINDING
KNOWN CRIMINALS BUT IT ALSO
SAVES THE STATE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN TIME AND
THE RESOURCES.
THE FIRST.
SEVENTH NINTH AND THE ELEVENTH
CIRCUIT COURTS.
HAVE ALL RULED.
THAT THE RECOGNIZING ENOUGH
PUBLIC SPACES SO DOES NOT THE
VIOLATE THE INDIVIDUAL ONE
PRIVACY RIGHTS.
AS A PUBLIC SPACE IS NOT JUST
THAT THE PUBLIC.
SO WHAT BY TRYING TO PASS THIS
TO BE A LOT WE ARE SAYING.
IT IS OKAY TO RECALL WHAT.
AND DON'T KNOW THE IDENTITY OF
OUR EVERY LAW ENFORCEMENT
INDIVIDUALS IN PUBLIC.
BUT IT IS ON NOT OKAY TO RECORD
AND THE NORMAL.
I IDENTITY OF THOSE ARE
INTERACTING WITH A LITTLE AND
FORCE MONTH.
I RESPECT THE OUR CONCERNS SO
THAT THE MY FELLOW ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HAS CEREBRAL TOWARD THE
UP WITH THIS BILL.
I UNFORTUNATELY FILLED OUT THE
THIS WAY LAW DECREASE AT THE
PROACTIVE WORK CUT UP THE LITTLE
ENFORCEMENT.
TOOL FOR OUR COMMUNITY IS TO AND
THE DEMAND -- I WANT INCREASE.
IN RESOURCES. TO OUR AGENCIES
ARE IN THE IN THE SEARCH AND UP.
APPREHENSION OF WELL KNOWN AND A
SUSPECT SUSPECTED CRIMINALS.
IT IS SO FOR THESE REASONS OF
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK THE FOR
YOUR NO VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOI.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISTER
TING YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AGAIN
RIGHT NOW WITH SO MANY BODY
CAMERAS BEING DEPLOYED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
I DO BELIEVE WITH THESE CAMERAS
MOSTLY ON IT IS IMPORTANT TO
PROTECT OUR PRIVACY.
ESPECIALLY FROM SOFTWARE THAT IS
VERY MUCH IN ACCURATE SO THAT WE
CAN'T HAVE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
BEING CONCERNED WE CAN'T HAVE
PEOPLE BEING FALSELY ACCUSED.
SO BY TAKING THIS PRECAUTION AS
WE DEPLOYED THESE CAMERAS ARE
ACROSS THE STATE.
I THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
STEP TO CONTINUE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE TRUST.
BETWEEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IN OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FRONT ON THANK YOU MISTER TEAM
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
TOM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A
MR TING MOVES THE CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY AB EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY AND
ACTUALLY THE SOLID WASTE.
MR MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB EIGHT TWO SEVEN
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA REACHED OUR
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS BY
HAVING RESTAURANTS PROVIDE BINS.
FOR RECYCLABLES AND COMPOST
WASTE IN THE FACILITIES.
IF ONLY WE CAN GET MEMBERS TO DO
THIS IN THE MEMBERS LOUNGE.
OUR SUBJECT.
CALIFORNIA HAS A REQUIREMENT
THAT 75% OF ORGANIC WASTE MUST
BE DIVERTED FROM LANDFILLS.
THAT MEANS IN FIVE YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAVE TO LEARN HOW TO
PROPERLY SORT THEIR WAYS
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS AND ISN'T
COMPOSED OF ALL.
NO EASY TASK GIVEN HOW OFTEN WE
EAT OUT WE KNOW THAT RESTAURANTS
ARE A GREAT PLACE TO START WE
ALSO KNOW THE RESTAURANTS ARE
YOU DOING THIS IF YOU TAKE IN
YOUR FAMILIES OVER THE YEARS.
TO AN ERA BREAD COSCO CHIPOTLE
THEY ALREADY HAVE MULTIPLE BANDS
ARE YOU CAN THROW YOUR TRASH
YOUR RECYCLING.
AND YOUR ORGANIC UNEATEN FOOD SO
THIS FRANKLY IS NOT THAT
COMPLICATED THIS IS A WIN WIN TO
HELP US REDUCE OUR GHGS AND HELP
CALIFORNIANS LEARN HOW TO
PROPERLY SORT OUT THEIR WASTE.
AND ALLOW US TO MAKE SMARTER
CHOICES ABOUT OUR CLIMATE --
RECEIVE NO NO VOTES SO FAR IN
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVALS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
QUIRK SILVA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER -- YES MADAM
SPEAKER I ALSO SUPPORT AB --
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN JUST
YESTERDAY WE HAD SOME OF ALL OUR
FRIENDS COME FROM CAL RECYCLED
TO REALLY TALK TO US AND
ACTUALLY SHOW US A SOME OF THE
PLASTIC PRODUCTS THAT WE BELIEVE
ARE RECYCLABLE BUT ACTUALLY
AREN'T.
AND I THINK THE MORE WE START TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE CAN RECYCLE
WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO -- AND
WHERE IT ACTUALLY IS WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO DO A BETTER JOB SO AS
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER I THINK IT IS
PART OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
UNDERSTAND THIS SO THAT WE CAN
ACTUALLY.
DO SOME TYPES OF WORKSHOPS -- TO
FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS ON
RECYCLING AND I ASK YOU TO
SUPPORT AB.
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MISS QUIRK SILVA SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE -- MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALONG MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
OF A YEAH.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY SIX KNOWS NINE
THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL
AND ACTUAL INTO RESIDENTIAL
RENTAL PROPERTY.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WOULD
MAKE IT EASIER FOR LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS TO ALLOW.
AN INDIVIDUAL AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS TO TEMPORARILY
RESIDE ON THEIR PROPERTY.
THIS BILL WAS INSPIRED BY
RESEARCHERS AT UCSF WHO HAVE
IDENTIFIED TEMPORARY HOUSING
WITH FAMILY OR FRIENDS AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO ENABLE
INDIVIDUALS AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS TO SECURE STE
SHELTER SAVE RESOURCES REGROUP
AND SEARCH FOR A MORE PERMANENT
OPTION.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT SEEKS TO
FACILITATE THIS PROCESS BY
PROTECTING TENANTS WHO WISHED TO
TEMPORARILY HOUSE A FAMILY
MEMBER FRIEND AND PROVIDES A
LEGAL FRAMEWORK THAT WILL
INCENTIVIZE BOTH LANDLORDS AND
TENANTS. TWO EGGS IT SAYS
PERSONS AT RISK OF HOME
HOMELESSNESS.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY FOUR
KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
READY TO LIFT THE CALL AND FILE
ITEM NINETY SEVEN AB FOURTEEN
TWENTY THREE THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
I'M MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS ART OF A ON
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED OF A CLERK
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTE AYE AYES FORTY FIVE NO SIX
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH SEVEN
AB ELEVEN OH SIX THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH ACTUALLY
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MISS SMITH YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS THE HOMEOWNER
NOTIFICATION PROGRAM HAS BEEN
SERVING LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HOMEOWNERS AND TENANTS SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE ENHANCED
HOMEOWNER NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
WAS ADOPTED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TO COMBAT THE EFFECTS OF
THE MORTGAGE CRISIS IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
IT HAS ALLOWED THE COUNTY TO
EXPAND SERVICES TO HOMEOWNERS
THAT INCLUDE COUNSELING SUPPORT
TENET RELOCATION SERVICES AND
LOAN MODIFICATION ASSISTANCE.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TO CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK
OF THE PROGRAM BY EXTENDING THE
SUNSET DATE.
TO TWENTY THIRTY THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION AND THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS SMITH SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTEEN
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE OF THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AS A LEGAL FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE
BY SOMETHING NUMBER SANTIAGO AND
ACTUALLY TO IMMIGRATION.
MR SANTIAGO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MAN SPEAKER AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE WOULD SIMPLY.
SIMPLY PREVENT ANYBODY FROM
IMPERSONATING A CENSUS WORKER
AND WE HAD A ROBUST.
DEBATE ABOUT THE THING
COMMITTEES ONLY BE CLEAR YES IT
WOULD PREVENT AN IMMIGRATION
OFFICIAL FROM REPRESENTING A
CENSUS WORKER BUT IT WOULD ALSO --
PREVENT SCAMMERS WHETHER FOLKS
ARE DOCUMENTS UNDOCUMENTED FROM
BEING SCAMMED BY HAVING SOMEBODY
REPRESENT -- A CENSUS WORKER IN
GATHERING INFORMATION FOR THEM
FOR ANY OTHER USE.
ODD THIS REPORT THIS -- BILL
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT'S AT STAKE
HERE WHAT'S AT STAKE ARE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS IN CAP THE COME TO
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT'S AT STAKE HERE IS ALSO
CONGRESSIONAL REPRESENTATION I
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT WE
COULD POTENTIALLY LOSE ALL
PEOPLES NOT COUNTY IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO THE
LONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY THREE KNOWS FOR THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTEEN
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY BY
SOMETHING NUMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY THE PREMARITAL
AGREEMENTS.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
CALIFORNIA LAW AN AXE
PROTECTIONS FOR PARTIES ENTERING
INTO PREMARITAL AGREEMENTS.
IN PARTICULAR THE LAW REQUIRES A
SEVEN DAY WAITING PERIOD BETWEEN
WHEN THE AGREEMENT IS DRAFTED
AND WHEN IT IS ASSIGNED TO MAKE
SURE THAT ALL PARTIES HAVE A
CHANCE TO REVIEW THE CONTENTS OF
THE AGREEMENT.
HOWEVER SOME DISAGREEMENT HAS
ARISEN OVER AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THAT SEVEN
DAY PERIOD STARTS FROM WHEN THE
INITIAL AGREEMENT IS DRAFTED OR
WHEN IT IS AMENDED.
AND WHETHER OR NOT THAT PERIOD
AND APPLIES TO BOTH REPRESENTED
AN ARBOR PRESENTED PARTIES.
THIS BILL AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
CLARIFIES THAT THE LAW SHOULD BE
INTERPRETED AS BROADLY AS
POSSIBLE THAT IT APPLIES TO
AMENDMENTS AS LONG AS THEY'RE
SUBSTANTIVE AND IT APPLIES TO
BOTH REPRESENTED AN UNDER
REPRESENTED PARTIES COLLEAGUES.
THIS WILL PROTECT CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS ENTERING INTO THESE
AGREEMENTS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE A THANK YOU MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
HOW LONG MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE?
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY FIVE NEW ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE NINETEEN
AB ONE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE BY FAMILY
MEMBER COOPER AND ACTUALLY THE
YOUTH ATHLETICS.
MISTERCOOPER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AB ONE ACTS THEY
BE STANDARDS FOR YOUTH TACKLE
FOOTBALL CONSISTENT WITH THE
STANDARDS THE HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL LEVEL.
THE BILL IN ITS GAMES BE CONTACT
DURING YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL
PRACTICES IT IMPLEMENTS THE MOST
REGION.
A COMPREHENSIVE SET OF SAFETY
STANDARDS IN THE COUNTRY FOR
YOUTH FOOTBALL SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL REQUIRES CONCUSSION
EDUCATION.
COACH TRAINING ENTRY TRACKING IN
THE PEN OBSERVATION OF PRACTICE
AND MEDICAL PERSONNEL ALL GAMES
FOR ALL YOUTH TACKLE FOOTBALL
LEAGUES.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OUT OF
COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS THAT HE DESIRED OF
A ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE ICE FIFTY NINE
NEWS ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MANY FILE ITEM ONE OH ONE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS AND
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING.
THIS WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
THINK EVERYONE CAN AGREE WE HAVE
TO BUILD MORE HOUSES.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE MISS WHAT'S
YOUR ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
I THINK EVERYONE AGREES WE HAVE
TO BUILD MORE HOUSING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WE NEED MORE HOUSING
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS.
WE ARE ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOME SHORT OF WHERE WE
NEED TO BE CALIFORNIA'S THE
HIGHEST POPULATION FOR LOWEST
NUMBER OF HOMES -- IN THE
COUNTRY -- SO IT'S IT'S CRITICAL
AND WE SEE THE RAMIFICATIONS OF
THIS IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE HAVE
PEOPLE SPENDING. 50% MORE -- ON
RENTS OF THEIR INCOME OR MORE ON
RENT WE SEE A MASSIVE INCREASE
IN HOMELESSNESS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND SO.
THERE'S BEEN A CHARGE BY THE
GOVERNOR AND THIS LEGISLATURE --
TO BUILD MORE HOUSING AND SO MY
BILL AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
WILL EXPAND EXISTING
STREAMLINING LAWS TO ENCOURAGE
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
PRODUCTION THIS IS ARE MISSING
MIDDLE THESE ARE FOLKS THAT.
DON'T QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING BUT THEY CAN'T AFFORD
THE CURRENT MARKET RATE.
WE NEED MORE MORE SUPPLIES SO
FOLKS CAN BUY MORE HOMES -- IN
OUR COMMUNITIES THIS IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS
SUPPORTED BY HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY -- THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
AND MANY OTHER GREAT
ORGANIZATIONS AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MRS WHERE X..
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TELLING ABOUT AYE AYES
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
TWO A. B. SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT BY SOME A MEMBER OBERNOLTE
AND ACTUALLY TO SEARCH WARRANTS
THROUGH OBERNOLTE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED OPEN ON THIS MATTER
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS
THE OFTEN VERY DIFFICULT TASK OF
INVESTIGATING THE CAUSES OF
VEHICULAR ACCIDENTS.
IN THIS -- TASK THE V. DATA FROM
THE EVENT DATA RECORDER WITH A
VEHICLE IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE.
THINGS LIKE THE SPEED OF THE
VEHICLE THE POSITION OF THE
STEERING WHEEL THE PERFORMANCE
OF THE AIRBAG SYSTEMS THINGS
THAT ARE CRITICAL TO DETERMINING
WHAT THE VEHICLE WAS DOING.
IN THE SECONDS IMMEDIATELY
PRECEDING THE ACCIDENT.
HOWEVER SOMETIMES LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS HAMPERED IN THEIR
ABILITY TO GET ACCESS THIS DATA
PARTICULARLY WHEN ON THE
ACCIDENT INVOLVED SERIOUSLY
BODILY INJURY OR DEATH AND THE
OWNER OF THE VEHICLE IS NOT
ALIVE TO GIVE CONSENT AT THE
ACCESS OF THIS INFORMATION.
SO THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT CREATES A VERY NARROWLY
CRAFTED ABILITY FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO ACCESS THIS DATA
IT IS ONLY IN THE CASE OF
SERIOUS BODILY INJURY.
OR DEATH.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE MR OBERNOLTE
YOUR ATTENTION.
ARE ONLY WITH THE PERMISSION OF
THE COURT AND ONLY A VERY NARROW
SUBSET OF DATA LOCATED ON THE
EVENT DATA RECORDER FIVE SECONDS
BEFORE IN SEVERAL SECONDS AFTER.
THE ACCIDENT.
COLLEAGUES THIS LEGISLATION
CRAFTS A BUT PROPERTY BALANCE
BETWEEN THE NEED TO PROTECT OUR
CONSUMER PRIVACY ON THE ONE HAND
AND THE NEED TO GIVE ACCESS TO
THIS DATA THAT'S VITAL FOR THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE ACCIDENTS
ON THE OTHER.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY
THREE NO SIX THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO VIOLATE IN ONE TWENTY
THREE AB SIXTEEN NINETY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
AND ACTUALLY THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS.
MR LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DURING THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX
FIRES AT WHAT WAS AT THAT POINT
IN TIME THE LARGEST BUYERS.
IN CALIFORNIA STATE HISTORY.
FIRE AGENCIES AND FIRST
RESPONDERS FROM ACROSS THE STATE
JOIN TOGETHER IN MUTUAL AID TO
FIGHT THAT FIRE.
WHEN SANTA CLARA COUNTIES FIRE
DEPARTMENT ROLLED UP ON TO THE
SCENE AND TRY TO COORDINATE WITH
OTHER AGENCIES?
THEY FOUND THAT THE DATA THAT
THEY WERE TRYING TO COORDINATE
WITH WAS SLOWED DOWN TO A
TRICKLE.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION MR LEVINE THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER THEIR DATA WAS
THROTTLED BY THEIR INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDER.
THEY CALLED TRIED.
TO HAVE THIS LIFTED -- THEY WERE
THROWN INTO -- A MARKETING --
ATTEMPT TO THAT LED THEM TO
ANOTHER PHONE NUMBER THAT THEY
HAD TO CALL AND IT WAS VERY
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO GET THE
DATA THEY NEEDED.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA
NINE HELD A HEARING WHERE WE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM CHIEF ABOUT
IN ABOUT THIS PROBLEM.
BUT LATER ON WHEN I DID SITE
VISITS WITH FIRST RESPONDERS AND
FIREFIGHTERS ACROSS THE STATE I
HEARD THAT THIS WAS NOT AN
ISOLATED INCIDENT.
AND SO AB SIXTEEN NINETY NINE
WILL PROHIBIT THE DATA
THROTTLING OF ANY FIRST
RESPONDERS NET DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE'S SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO THE
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
A ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO
THIS MEASURE PASSES. NINETY FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
NINETY THREE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX NINETY THREE
BY SOMETHING MEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION IS THE TERM OF ART
WE USE FOR SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION.
CURRENTLY A CONDITIONAL VOTERS
GIVEN A PROVISIONAL BALLOT WHICH
IS PROCESSED AFTER ELECTION DAY
DURING THE CAMPUS PERIOD.
USING VOTE CAL THE STATE'S NEW
VOTER DATABASE ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS CAN NOW VERIFY FOR
VOTERS ELIGIBLE IMMEDIATELY AN
UPDATE THE DATABASE IN REAL TIME.
THIS MEANS THAT THE SAME PROCESS
TO VERIFY CONDITIONAL
REGISTRANTS ELIGIBILITY THAT
CURRENTLY OCCURS ON THE BACK AND
AFTER ELECTION DAY CAN NOW HOP
HAPPEN ON THE FRONT END IN REAL
TIME.
THEREFORE AB SIX NINETY THREE
WOULD AUTHORIZE AN ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL TO OFFER A NON
PROVISIONAL OR REGULAR BALLOT TO
A CONDITIONALLY REGISTERED VOTER
PROVIDED THAT THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL CAN COMPLETE THE
VERIFICATION.
UNDER A CERTAIN SET OF
CONDITIONS.
IF THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL CANNOT
VERIFY OR THE CONNECTION TO THE
VOTER DATABASES INTERRUPTED AT
ANY TIME.
THE VOTER WOULD STILL BE ISSUED
A PROVISIONAL BALLOT THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE ANYTHING ABOUT
THE CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS IT JUST
CHANGES WHEN AT THAT PROCESS CAN
OCCUR IT WILL IMPROVE THE VOTER
EXPERIENCE.
AND LOWER THE NUMBER PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS THAT NEED TO BE
PROCESSED AFTER ELECTION DAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER YES THANK YOU MAN
SPEAKER WE SAW THIS BILL IN
ELECTIONS COMMITTEE -- AND YOU
KNOW THE THE ESSENTIAL ISSUE AND
PROBLEM WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
THERE ARE STILL A LOT OF
PROBLEMS AS VOTE CAL -- AS WE
KNOW THERE WERE PEOPLE THAT WERE
IMPROPERLY REGISTERED -- IN THE
LAST.
ELECTION THERE'S BEEN ISSUES
WHERE THERE HAS BEEN HAS BEEN A
NEED TO CLEAN UP.
AB VOTER ROLLS FOR EXAMPLE IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- AND SO
UNTIL WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE A
VERY ACCURATE VOTE CAL.
DATABASE I THINK IT'S PREMATURE
TO AUTOMATICALLY.
ESSENTIALLY TAKE AWAY THE THE
CHECKING OF THESE PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS.
THESE WOULD BE CAST AS
PROVISIONAL BALLOTS UNDER.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AND BE DOUBLE
CHECK TO ENSURE THERE HADN'T
BEEN -- A VOTE FOR FOR EXAMPLE
IN ANOTHER JURISDICTION -- AN
ABSENTEE VALLEY CASSON AND
ANOTHER JURISDICTION AND IT'S AN
IMPORTANT CHECK THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE -- SO I WOULD ASK THAT WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL AS I I BELIEVE
IT'S PREMATURE UNTIL WE KNOW WE
HAVE AN ACCURATE BUT CAL
DATABASE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER MISTER
BERMAN YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL I
ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
OF MY VICE CHAIR.
OF THE MEMBER FROM NICHOLAS I I
I I WANNA MAKE SURE YOU HE'S NOT
MISREPRESENTING WHAT THIS BILL
DOES.
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
PROCESS AT ALL.
SO THE SAME PROCESS WILL OCCUR
IT WILL JUST OCCUR WHEN SOMEBODY
GOES INTO VOTE AS OPPOSED TO
TWENTY FIVE DAYS AFTER ELECTION
DAY YEAH IT'S A BETTER PROCESS
FOR VOTERS IT STILL MAINTAINS
THE VOTER SECURITY PROCEDURES.
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE TODAY IT
DOES NOT CHANGE THAT ONE IOTA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN THE
CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
LOW'S THE ROLLING TALLY THE VOTE
AYE AYES FIFTY TWO NO SIXTEEN
THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SIX AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO ELECTIONS.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
EXISTING AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO PUT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AT THE
FINGERTIPS FOR VOTERS.
MAKING VOTING EASIER AND ENHANCE
VOTER ENGAGEMENT.
OF VOTER CAN RECEIVE THE STATE
VOTER INFORMATION GOT
ELECTRONICALLY BRING UP THE
GUIDE ON A SMARTPHONE OR TABLET
AND IMMEDIATELY ACCESS
INFORMATION SUCH AS DONORS TO A
MEASURE.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY IS WORKING ON
A NEW VOTING SYSTEM WITH THE
OPTION FOR VOTERS TO SCAN IN Q.
ARE COATED BALLOTS FROM THEIR
PHONE TO THE VOTING TERMINALS AT
POLLING PLACES.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR ELECTION LAWS
DO NOT RECOGNIZE THE USE OF SUCH
DEVICES AND SOME ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS IMPORTERS OF QUESTION
THE PERMISSIBILITY OF USING
SMARTPHONES OR TABLETS AT THE
POLLS.
AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN WOULD
CLARIFY THAT A PERSON MAY NOT BE
PROHIBITED FROM USING AN
ELECTRONIC DEVICE AT A POLLING
PLACE PROVIDED THAT THE USE DOES
CONFLICT WITH EXISTING LAWS.
THAT ENSURE THAT VOTING IS A
PRIVATE AND IS PRIVATE AND FREE
FROM INTIMIDATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FIFTY SIX NOW ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN AB ONE TWENTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE TWENTY EIGHT
BY SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY DIVORCES.
MR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
I RISE TO PRESENT EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH WILL STRENGTH
AND LONG STANDING PROTECTIONS IN
LAW AGAINST THE SLAUGHTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S WILD AND DOMESTIC
COURSES.
THIS RECENT AMENDMENTS HAVE
REMOVED THE CALL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAUS OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO VIOLATE ONE TWENTY
NINE AB SIX TWENTY FOUR THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL AND
ACTUALLY THE PEOPLE INSTEAD
HEALTH.
MR GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB SIX
TWO FOUR WHICH WILL REQUIRE
SCHOOLS THAT USED TO ISSUE
STUDENT ID CARDS TO INCLUDE
PHONE NUMBERS FOR SEXUAL ASSAULT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH OUTLINES
ON THE ID.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS LEGISLATION
IS TO ENSURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY THOSE FACING A
CHALLENGING SITUATION ARE ABLE
TO ACCESS TIMELY AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION THAT MAY BE A
CENTRAL TO THEIR PHYSICAL OR
MENTAL WELL BEING.
UNFORTUNATE THERE'S A REAL AN
URGENT NEED FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS INFORMATION.
STATISTICS DEMONSTRATE THAT ONE
IN THREE TEENS -- EXPERIENCE
TEEN DATING VIOLENCE ONE IN NINE
GIRLS WERE EXPERIENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR ABUSE BEFORE.
EIGHTEEN AN STI RATES CONTINUE
TO RISE AMONG CALIFORNIA'S TEENS
AND YOUNG ADULTS.
AB SIX TWO FOUR WOULD MAKE THIS
INFORMATION MORE EASILY
ACCESSIBLE ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE
WHOSE INTERNET USAGE MAYBE AND
MONITORED BY AN ABUSER I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL.
MISTER GALLAGHER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER -- YES
MAN SPEAKER RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW.
I THINK LAST YEAR WE KIND OF
STARTED THIS PROCESS WE SAID HEY
THERE'S AN ISSUE WITH SUICIDE --
TEEN SUICIDE SO WE ADDED A
HOTLINE NUMBER. TWO ID'S BUT NOW
WE'RE STARTING TO ADD ALL KINDS
OF OTHER THINGS.
SCHOOLS SHOULD HAVE THE RIGHT.
I BELIEVE THE NOT HAVE THEIR
STUDENT ID'S COMMANDEERED.
BY US AT THE STATE GOVERNMENT IS
START TELLING THEM WHAT THEY
SHOULD PUT.
ON THEIR STUDENT ID'S THAT
SHOULD REALLY BE UP TO LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARDS AT THEIR
DISCRETION TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
THEY WANT TO HAVE -- AND
CERTAINLY WE ALREADY HAVE IN OUR
SCHOOLS MANDATORY -- SEXUAL
EDUCATION AND OTHER PROGRAMMING.
BOBBI IT THERE'S SOME
DISAGREEMENT OVER WHAT THAT
SHOULD BE -- AS WAS EVIDENCED
YESTERDAY AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION -- BUT
THE ISSUE OF MANDATING NOW THAT
WE HAVE THE CERTAIN HOTLINE
NUMBERS THAT.
REALLY START ARE STARTING TO
SEEM LIKE INTEREST GROUPS.
SPECIFICALLY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
TRYING TO GET THEMSELVES ON A
STUDENT ID.
THAT STATE THAT THAT -- STUDENTS
WITHIN CONTACT -- I DON'T THINK
IS APPROPRIATE.
AND NOT A GOOD USE OF OUR STATE
POWERS LET'S LEAVE THIS UP TO
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS TO MAKE THAT
DECISION ABOUT WHAT SHOULD BE ON
THEIR STUDENT ID'S.
THANK YOU AND ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER.
IS YOUR GAME REALLY MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE --
I THINK THAT THE DATA BEARS OUT
THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT
INFORMATION FOR YOUNG PEOPLE TO
HOUSE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
AYE AYES FORTY NINE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
AB SIX SIXTY THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND ACTING
TO ENERGY.
MR LIVING YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SEAKER MEMBERS EIGHTY SIX
SIXTY WILL DOUBLE THE REFLECTIVE
STANDARD OF OUR ROOFTOPS MAKING
IT EASIER -- TO COOL OUR HOMES
AND ALSO REDUCE.
THE EFFECTS OF COOLING ON
CLIMATE CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE SEEING
AND HEARING.
NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS MATTER
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS GO TO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
EIGHT KNOWS THIRTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
SOMETHING MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA
AND ACTUALLY THE DRINKING WATER.
THIS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER YES GOOD
MORNING AB SEVEN FIVE SIX WOULD
ALLOW THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD. TO ISSUE ONE
NOTICED INSTEAD OF HUNDREDS OF
NOTICES AS THEY MOVE INTO PHASE
TWO OF INVESTIGATIVE TASTING FOR
P. -- FIVE CLEAR UP SOME
CONFUSION THIS BILL DOES NOT
AUTHORIZE THE TESTING AS I WATER
ROLLER ALREADY HAS THE AUTHORITY.
THIS IS THE ISN'T TEFLON AS WELL
AS FIREFIGHTING PHONE FORMULATED
FOR PUTTING NOT FEEL FIRES
UTILIZED TAKING ON A FACE
INVESTIGATIVE TESTING OF SYSTEMS.
THAT ARE SUSPECTED TO HAVE
CONTAMINATION.
THIS FAMILY A CHEMICALS HAVE
BEEN LINKED TO CANCER AND BIRTH
DEFECTS THIS BILL WILL HELP FIND
OUT THE SCOPE OF THE PROBLEMS
ARE IN MEDIATION CAM BEGAN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I FIFTY TWO NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY TWO
AB EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ.
A SIZEABLE EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT BY
SOMETHING MEMBER LOW AND
ACTUALLY CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
MR LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MINISTER MEMBERS AB
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT A PROVIDES
THAT.
WE HAVE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS
OFFER AS REFERRALS FOR NON --
EIGHT TREATMENTS IN ADDRESSING
THIS.
CRISIS THAT WE HAVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEING IN
HEARINGNO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE.
TO ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
OF A THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE.
I FIFTY SIX KNOWS HERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
WE ARE READY TO LIFT THE CALL
AND FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED AB.
TWELVE FIFTEEN THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
MOM MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEEN THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY
THREE AB TEN SEVENTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN SEVENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
AND ACTUALLY TO IMMIGRATION.
IS RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS TODAY I'M
PRESENTING AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
WHICH AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ENTER INTO AN
AGREEMENT WITH IMMIGRATION AND
CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT. TO LIMIT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES AT THE
VICTIM SERVICE LOCATIONS
MENTIONED.
IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN MODEL
POLICIES ON IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
EXISTING OPERATE AT THE STATE OR
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
INCLUDING SCHOOL POLICE AND
SECURITY DEPARTMENTS FROM USING
MONEY OR PERSONNEL TO
INVESTIGATE.
INTERROGATE DETAINED DETECT --
ARREST PERSONS FOR IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES.
SB.
FIFTY FOUR REQUIRED THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ESTABLISH MODEL
POLICIES LIMITING ASSISTANCE
WITH IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT TO
THE FULLEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE HAD ORGANIZATIONS REACH
OUT TO US AND INFORM US THAT
THEY HAVE SEEN A DECLINE IN
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
SEEKING SERVICES FOR DOMESTIC
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE SINCE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE I WHAT I
WAS IN UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
AND I HAVE AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBER WAS A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE FEARS THE
STRESS THE CONFUSION OF TRYING
TO SURVIVE MOMENT BY MOMENT.
KNOWING YOU CAN BE TORN FROM
YOUR FAMILY AND DEPORTED AT ANY
TIME.
THIS YEAR'S REAL AND IT'S
SOMETHING I WILL NEVER FORGET.
I KNOW THE PAIN OF MY FATHER
BEING ASKED FOR HIS DOCUMENTS
AND BEING UNABLE TO PROVIDE THEM.
I KNOW THE VISION MY PARENTS HAD
FOR US A VISION THAT IS
FULFILLED AS BOTH ME AND MY
SISTER SERVING IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE PAIN
MY FAMILY MEMBERS WENT THROUGH
WHEN THEIR SPOUSE WAS BEATING
THEM.
I UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO ASK FOR HELP WITH PROPER
DOCUMENT WITHOUT PROPER
DOCUMENTATION.
MOST UNDOCUMENTED SURVIVORS ARE
TOO AFRAID TO ASK FOR HELP.
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF BEING
RIPPED AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
LET ME BE CLEAR ICE CANNOT BE
PERMANENTLY STOPPED FROM
ENTERING THESE LOCATIONS.
HOWEVER AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
WILL HELP REMEDY THESE FEARS BY
WORKING WITH ICE ON HELPING
PROTECT THE SURVIVORS IN THESE
LOCATIONS.
MADAM SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY BOOK.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO MR GABRIEL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
SEVENTY THREE WANT TO THANK OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK FOR
BRING FOR THE SUPPORT MEASURE.
THIS IS A PRIORITY BILL FOR THE
JEWISH CAUCUS ONE OF THE CENTRAL%
TENETS OF OUR TRADITION IS OUR
COLLECTIVE RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
AMONG US I THINK THAT'S A A
COMMON THEME WE SEE IN A LOT OF
RELIGIOUS TRADITIONS.
AND IT'S HARD TO THINK OF A
POPULATION THAT IS MORE
VULNERABLE THAN UNDOCUMENTED
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND
SO ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS.
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU MR GABRIEL MYSTERY ARE
YOU MAY CLOSE ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU.
I RISK I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES FIFTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
MEMBERS.
WE ARE FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY FOUR AB.
ELEVEN FIFTY CALGARY.
ASSEMBLY BILL LEVIN FIFTY BY
SOMETHING MEMBER GLORIA AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
MR GLORIA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN FIFTY
MEMBERS IS THE DISTRICT BILL IT
WOULD REQUIRE CANDIDATES FOR THE
SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT.
AND THE GROSSMONT CUYAMACA
COLLEGE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT TO COLLECT AT LEAST ONE
HUNDRED SIGNATURES.
FROM VOTERS IN THEIR TRUSTY AREA
IN ORDER TO SUPPORT.
IN ORDER TO QUALIFY TO APPEAR ON
THE BALLOT -- ELECTIONS FOR
THOSE GOVERNING BOARDS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THE THERE WAS GLORIA SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK LIBERAL.
MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THE ALL
MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS OUT OF THOSE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE.
TELL YOU ABOUT.
AYE AYES FORTY SIX KNOWS.
ELEVEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WE'RE GOING TO PASS A RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE AND
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY SIX WE ARE FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY SEVEN A. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY ONE BY MISS POWER QUE HAN
COOKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN TWENTY
ONE BY SOMETHING MEMBER BAUER
QUE HAN AND ACTUALLY TO
SUPERVISED RELEASE.
MS BARRICADE HAND YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY ONE A BILL
WHICH BROKE WOULD PROHIBIT RE
ARRESTING INCARCERATING AN
INDIVIDUAL ON PROBATION WHO IS
OTHERWISE ABIDING BY THE TERMS
OF HIS OR HER SUPERVISION.
SOLELY ON THE BASIS OF THEIR
INABILITY TO PAY COURT ORDERED
FEES FINES OR ASSESSMENTS.
EVERY TIME WE WERE BROKEN
INDIVIDUAL FOR A PROBATION
VIOLATION FOR THE THIRTY DAYS
THEY STAY IN JAIL WE SPEND FOUR
THOUSAND FOURTEEN THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS VERSES THAN BEING ON
SUPERVISED PROBATION.
WHEN INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF A
CRIME THE COURT MAY ISSUE
PENALTIES SUCH AS JAIL TIME AND
FINES FEES ASSESSMENTS
RESTITUTION?
AT THE TIME OF SENTENCING THE
ABILITY FOR A DEFENDANT TO PAY
MONETARY PENALTIES IS NOT ALWAYS
CONSIDERED DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THE SUPREME COURT HAS SAID.
THE COURT MUST CONSIDER SUCH
ITEMS.
WE ON EQUALLY SENATE INDIVIDUAL
BACK TO JAIL FOR THEIR INABILITY
TO PAY.
BY REVOKING PROBATION TO ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO LACKS THE ABILITY
TO PAY AND OTHERWISE IS MEETING
ALL THE TERMS OF THE SUPERVISION
THE COURT AND PROBATION ARE IN
ESSENCE DRIVING OR INDIVIDUALS
INTO DEEPER POVERTY.
AND INCARCERATING THEM BECAUSE
THEY ARE POOR.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT ITS COMMITTEES AND
HAS NO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BACKING HIM SAYING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM [inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF HER DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRABLE
[inaudible]
CLICK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF WHAT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM.
ONE THIRTY EIGHT IS A. B.
SIXTEEN OH SEVEN BY MS BERGER
**** BATH CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
BY SOME REMEMBER BURNER FOR THAT
AND ACTUALLY TO CIVIL RIGHTS.
MISS BURKHALTER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
WILL REQUIRE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THAT ISSUE LOCAL BUSINESS
LICENSE TO ISSUE A NOTICE OF
BUSINESS. TO A BUSINESS WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE GENDER TAX
REPEAL ACT AT THE TIME THE
BUSINESS RECEIVES ITS BUSINESS
LICENSE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AS YOU KNOW
THE GENDER TAX REPEAL ACT
PROHIBITS BUSINESSES FROM
CHARGING DIFFERENT PRICES FOR
SERVICES BASED ON GENDER.
THE CHALLENGES THAT MANY
BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE NOT AWARE THAT
THIS LAW EVEN EXISTS.
AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN WILL REQUIRE
A CITY OR COUNTY TO ISSUE A
NOTICE OF THE GENDER TAX REPEAL
ACT OF THE TIME THE BUSINESS
RECEIVES ITS BUSINESS LICENSE.
THIS BILL HASN'T.
AND HAS NOT RECEIVE NO NO VOTES
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU MS BOERNER HORVATH
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A MOM
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY THREE KNOWS THERE THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
OBERNOLTE AND ACTUALLY THE
COURTS.
MR OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
CURRENTLY STATE LAW LIMITS TRIAL
COURTS TO KERRY RESERVES OF ONLY
UP 21% OF THEIR ANNUAL OPERATING
BUDGETS.
THE MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR
TRIAL COURTS TO BUDGET FOR
FUTURE EXPENSES BETWEEN
DIFFERENT FISCAL YEARS
ESPECIALLY CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
FOR EXAMPLE TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS
THIS BILL AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN WOULD REMOVE THAT 1% CAP.
THIS WOULD IMPROVE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND GIVE US A BETTER
COURT SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE
SEEING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THIS
MATTER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY
SIX NO ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
ONE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT BY SELLING MEMBER BONTA
AND ACTUALLY TO EMPLOYMENT.
MR BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT WHICH
CONFORMS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACT OR CFRA. TO THE
UNIQUE WORK SCHEDULE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF FLIGHT CREW
MEMBERS AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DONE IN THE
FEDERAL FAMILY AND MEDICAL LEAVE
ACT OR FMLA.
DUE TO THE NATURE OF THEIR WORK
FULL TIME FLIGHT CREW MEMBERS
WORK A SCHEDULE OF THREE TO FOUR
DAYS AND THIS DOES NOT MAKE THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CFRA AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT WOULD MORE
APPROPRIATELY.
USE FM LA IT'S WORK OUR
REQUIREMENT OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
FOUR HOURS LIKE PROOF CFRA.
ELIGIBILITY THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MONTEZ SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS WHO DESERVE IT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTE.
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THIS
MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
TWO AB ONE SIXTY TO THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KILEY AND
ACTUALLY THE COMMUNICATIONS.
MR KILEY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER.
THIS IS A BILL TO STOP THE TAXED
TAX.
IT'S A BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
TEXTING.
IF NOTHING ELSE REMAINS TAX FREE
IN CALIFORNIA.
AS WE ALL KNOW TEXT MESSAGING
HAS BECOME INTEGRAL TO MODERN
COMMUNICATION.
I'M SURE MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
CHAMBER SEND DOZENS OF TAX TODAY.
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE IT CAN BE
HUNDREDS.
A PROPOSAL RECENTLY FLOATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WOULD HAVE TURNED ALL
OF OUR TAXING.
INTO A TAXABLE ACTIVITY BY
EXTENDING SURCHARGES AUTHORIZED
UNDER STATE LAW.
WELL THE PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
WITHDRAWN FOR THE TIME BEING
FOLLOWING A FEDERAL RULING THE
TEXT MESSAGES ARE CONSIDERED AN
FOR AN INFORMATION SERVICE.
ADVOCATES OF THE TEXT TAX ARE
STILL INSISTENCE ON MOVING IT
FORWARD.
BUT WE AS LAWMAKERS CONTAINER.
LIVING IN CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY
ON AFFORDABLE FOR FAR TOO MANY
PEOPLE.
BECOMING THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO TAX TEXTING.
WOULD ONLY MAKE THINGS WORSE.
I TAX TAX WOULD HIT EVERY
CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT IT THOSE LIVING IN
POVERTY YOUNG PEOPLE'S YOUNG
PEOPLE AND SENIORS ON FIXED
INCOMES HARDEST OF ALL.
THAT'S WHY AB ONE SIXTY TWO WILL
CREATE A STATUTORY WILL CREATE
STATUTORY LAW THAT BARS ANY TAX
TAX.
PROHIBITING THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION FROM EXTENDING TAXES
FEES AND SURCHARGES TO TEXT
MESSAGING OR OTHER INFORMATION
SERVICES.
THIS BILL HAS TWENTY FIVE CO
AUTHOR IS THE THIRD MOST OF ANY
BILL IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR AND PASSED OUT OF COMMITTEE
WITH UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED OF
THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE.
TO OKAY MISTER KILEY MOVES THE
CALL.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. ONE FORTY
FOUR ACR FIFTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FIFTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND OTHERS RELATIVE THE
SAYS QUIZ CENTENNIAL CELEBRATION
OF THE FIRST TRANSCONTINENTAL
RAILROAD.
MR LYNN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CELEBRATE A
LANDMARK MOMENT IN AMERICAN
HISTORY AND THE PEOPLE.
WHO MADE IT POSSIBLE THERE ARE
FEW THINGS MORE FUNDAMENTAL TO
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
NATION AND PARTICULARLY THE WEST
IN CALIFORNIA?
THEN THE COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD ON MAY
TENTH EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD
TRANSFORMED A COAST TO COAST
TRIP.
FROM.
EIGHTY SIX ORDER IN THE CHAMBER
THANK YOU MANAGE YOUR FROM A SIX
MONTH JOURNEY TO A SIX DAY TRIP.
THE REAL ROAD BECAME A KEY
ENGINE IN OUR NATION'S ECONOMIC
AND SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT.
TODAY WE CELEBRATE THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE COMPLETION OF THE REAL
ROAD WHICH WAS BUILT EASTWARD
FROM RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA TO PROMONTORY SUMMIT
UTAH.
WITH THE CENTRAL PACIFIC
RAILROAD MERGE WITH THE WESTWARD
BILL UNION PACIFIC RAILROAD IN
THE GOLDEN SPIKE CEREMONY.
THE MOST DIFFICULT SECTION IN
THE BUILDING OF THE RAILROAD WAS
IN THE RUGGED SIERRA NEVADA
MOUNTAINS.
WITH AS MUCH AS 90% OF THE
CENTRAL PACIFIC WORK FORCE WAS
CHINESE AND THEY MET THE
CHALLENGES HEAD ON THE TRANS CON
IN CONTINENTAL RAILROAD COULD
NOT HAVE BEEN BUILT WITHOUT
THEIR IMMIGRANT.
LABOR WITHOUT WHAT THEY'VE DONE
THE WEST COULD HAVE TURNED OUT
QUITE DIFFERENTLY.
AND THIS MOMENT THIS CESSPOOL
CENTENNIAL CELEBRATION.
HAS A PARALLEL ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
YEARS LATER TO TODAY AS WELL.
TOMORROW VERY FEW PEOPLE WILL
GET RICH ON AN IPO ON THE BACKS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO LABOR
ON SUBSISTENCE WAGES DRIVING
PEOPLE AROUND.
WITH TRANSPORTATION MUCH LIKE
HAPPENED WITH THE RAILROAD ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS AGO TODAY
MADAM SPEAKER -- WHEN THE
OPPORTUNITY ARISES I'D LIKE TO
OPEN THIS ROLL UP FOR CO AUTHORS?
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE MR FONG
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
A MEMBERS I RISE TODAY IS A
PROUD JOIN AUTHOR OF ACR FIFTY
ONE COMMEMORATING THE ONE
HUNDRED FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY OF
THE COMPLETION OF THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD.
IN EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR THE FIRST
NON CHINESE WORKERS FOR THE
CENTRAL PACIFIC RAILROAD COMPANY
ARRIVED AGAINST IF WORK FACING
GRUELING CONDITIONS.
AND START WITH A GROUP OF TWENTY
ONE MAN THE CLEAR THE DUTCH FLAT
DAUGHTER LAKE WAGON ROAD USING
HAND TOOLS AND MULES JUST EASIER
SACRAMENTO.
THE PROJECT INVOLVED THOUSANDS
OF WORKERS MANY OF WHOM WERE
CHINESE AN IRISH IMMIGRANTS AND
NATIVE AMERICANS AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND OTHERS WHO JOINED
TO WORK TOGETHER TO CONSTRUCT
THIS PROJECT.
CHINESE WORKERS MADE UP ABOUT
80% OF THE WESTERN WORKFORCE
TODAY WE COMMEMORATE THE
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS MANY OF
WHOM GAVE THEIR LIVES TO
TRANSFORM THE WEST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER FONG MISTER TO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE API LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS AND AS A REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE OLDEST CHINATOWN IN THE
COUNTRY I'M PLEASED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF ACR.
FIFTY ONE SINCE THE FIRST
OPENING ON MAY THE TENTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE THE CENTRAL
PACIFIC RAILROAD BECAME THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR STATES
ECONOMIC SUCCESS.
BRINGING IN BENEFITS FROM THE
EXPANSION OF OUR POPULATION TO
INDUSTRY AND TO AGRICULTURE.
AND AS WE ALL KNOW NEARLY TWELVE
THOUSAND CHINESE IMMIGRANTS WERE
EMPLOYED IN THE CONSTRUCTION OF
THIS RAILROAD. 80% OF THE
WORKFORCE OF HE RAILROAD
COMPANY.
THE INJURED MANY HARDSHIPS IN
CASUALTIES INCLUDING AN
UNSUCCESSFUL STRIKE FOR BETTER
PAY AND HAVING TO STRIKE WHEN
THE LINE WAS COMPLETE IN ORDER
TO BE PAID AT ALL.
THROUGH THEIR FIGHT AGAINST
DISCRIMINATION CHINESE WERE
WORKERS SET AN EXAMPLE FOR
FUTURE GENERATIONS OF WORKERS AS
WELL AS API ACTIVISTS BY
ADVANCING IDEALS OF EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY.
AND THE DIGNITY OF WORK.
HOPE YOU CAN JOIN ALL OF US IN
CELEBRATING CALIFORNIA RAILROAD
DAY AND RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION OF
CHINESE AMERICANS BY SUPPORTING
A C. R..
FIFTY ONE THANK YOU MISTER TO
MISTER PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
I RISE -- ALSO TO SUPPORT -- AND
THAT SUGGESTS THAT.
SOME OF YOU MEMBERS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO GO -- ON THE RAILROAD --
TO DENVER AND ALL THAT THAT YOU
WILL HAVE AN UNBELIEVABLE TOUR.
BY GOING ON THE RAILROAD BETWEEN
SACRAMENTO WHEN UP TO RENO.
AND THERE WILL BE -- THE
RAILROAD MUSEUM DOCENTS WILL BE
ON BOARD THAT TRAIN.
AND AS YOU GO THROUGH ALL THOSE
TUNNELS AND YOU SEE ALL OF THE
WORK THAT WAS DONE THEY WILL
GIVE YOU A THOROUGH CLEAR
COMPLETE HISTORY OF IT.
AND IT IS ABSOLUTELY AMAZING
MUCH OF WHAT HAS BEEN SAID ON
THE FLOOR.
YOU'LL GET TO SEE THE RESULT OF
AND HAVE IT THOROUGHLY AND
HISTORICALLY EXPLAINED WHEN YOU
TAKE THAT TRAIN TRIP BUT I WOULD
SUGGEST YOU TAKE IT SHARON AND
I'VE DONE IT TWICE.
AND ABSOLUTELY LOVE IT.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION MR
LEVINE IS ASK THAT THE FIRST
ROLL THE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
THIS VOTE IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
THERE ARE SIXTY SIX CO AUTHORS
ON ACR FIFTY ONE WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
SOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FIVE A. B. TWELVE FIFTY TO THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY TO
BUY SOMETHING NUMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND OTHERS AN EXCELLENT
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION.
SERVICE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
FIFTY TWO ALLOWS THE CALIFORNIA
E. PA TO SHOULD VANCE PAYMENTS.
THE PAYMENTS FOR GRANTS AWARDED
UNDER THE ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
SMALL GRANT PROGRAM.
A GRANTSARE AWARDED FOR
PROJECTS.
RIGHT IN SERVICE -- TO THE
DISADVANTAGE OR LOW INCOME --
COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE SUCH
PROJECTS SEEK TO IMPROVE ACCESS
TO CLEAN WATER ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS IN REDUCE
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC CHEMICALS THIS
MEASURE HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER RIVAS THIS
RIVAS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AS CHAIR OF THE RIVAS
CAUCUS I SUPPORT.
MY VICE CHAIR I'M A FIRST BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS RIVAS YOUR FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF MYSTERY THIS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SIX NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
SIX AB SIX OH TO THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX OH TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND
ACTUALLY TO PRIVACY.
MR BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES SB SIX OH TWO WOULD
EXPAND CALIFORNIA'S REVENGE PORN
STATUTE TO ACCOUNT FOR WHAT ARE
COMMONLY KNOWN.
AS DEEP FAKES DEPICTS ARE HYPER
REALISTIC PICTURES VIDEOS AND
AUDIO RECORDINGS OF AN
INDIVIDUAL FALSELY APPEARING TO
DO OR SAY SOMETHING.
AND THEY HAVE PREDOMINANTLY BEEN
USED TO HARASS AND HUMILIATE
WOMEN BY SOME SCRAPING THEIR
PHOTOS FROM THE INTERNET AND
MANIPULATING THEM.
INTO SEXUALLY EXPLICIT MATERIAL.
RECOGNIZING THAT A PERSON WHO
FALSELY APPEARS IN A DEEP FAKE
PORN VIDEO CAN BE JUST AS
TRAUMATIZED AND VICTIMIZED AS
ANY VICTIM OVER REVENGE PORN.
SB SIX SO TWO WOULD GRANT A
VICTIM OF AN AFFAIR IS SEXUALLY
EXPLICIT DEEP FAKE THE SAME
RIGHTS.
AND CIVIL REMEDIES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FOR A VICTIM
OF REVENGE PORN THIS BILL
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER BERMAN SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR OWN.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRED
OF THE ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE TO FILE ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY WILL FOURTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
AND I PLAN TO BUSINESS.
SIR GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AB
FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THE PENALTIES COLLECTED
BY ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEY FROM
ACTION UNDER THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION ACT BE PAID ENTIRELY
TO THE CITY ATTORNEY'S -- TO THE
CITY THAT BROUGHT THE
PROSECUTION BY ENSURING THE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
PENALTIES ARE AWARDED UNDER THIS
ACT THIS BILL WILL EMPOWER THOSE
ELIGIBLE CITY ATTORNEYS TO
PROSECUTE UNFAIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES -- BE UNFAIR BUSINESS
IS AN INTEREST OF CONSUMERS AND
OF THE ENVIRONMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO BOTH
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FORTY
NINE KNOWS ELEVEN THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
THREE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY TO TRANSPORTATION.
MISS GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER [inaudible]
YEAH AS MADAM SPEAKER AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY WOULD EXTEND
THE DEADLINE OF SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS TO
FINALIZE A NEW REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
BY TWO YEARS THE REGION WILL
NEED A PLAN TO START FROM
SCRATCH OR TO GET IT RIGHT MAKE
MEANINGFUL CHANGES TO MEET THE
REDUCTION TARGETS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELLING VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS
HERE THIS MEASURE PASSES.
WE FILE ITEM EIGHT ONE FIFTY
FOUR AB SEVEN THE CLERK WILL
READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN BY SOMETHING
MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO THE COMPUTATION OF
TIME TO CLEARING THE URGENCY
THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MOTHER
IN CHAIRS AND MEMBERS I RISE 2%
AB SEVEN WHICH WILL SET
CALIFORNIA.
ON DAYLIGHT SAVING TIME ALL YEAR
PENDING FEDERAL APPROVAL.
IF PASS THIS BILL WILL GO INTO
EFFECT IN MARCH FOLLOWING
FEDERAL OTHER ALSO RIGHT THE XIN.
STUDY HELPED SHOWN THAT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF FOR A BI
ANNUAL TIMES WHICH INCLUDING
INCREASING TRAFFIC WORKPLACE AT
ACCIDENT HEART ATTACK AND STROKE.
AND SO ON AND SO FORTH WELL
WHILE THE PRACTICE WAS STARTED
TO SAVE ENERGY.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT DUE TO THE
CHANGE IN ENERGY CONSUMPTION
PATTON IT NO LONGER DOES SO.
IN FACT THE POLICY COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NOTED THAT THE PRACTICE
EVEN HOUSE POTENTIAL BENEFITS
FOR UTILIZING SOLAR ENERGY.
IN IN -- TWENTY NINETEEN DOES
FAR WE HAVE SEARCHED THE NIGHT
TO THE STATE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN IN INTRODUCED --
LEGISLATION EXPRESSING THE
INTEREST IN ELIMINATING THE BAR
ANNUAL TIME SWITCH AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA VOTER PASSED A A. B..
SEVEN LAST YEAR AND WILL
CERTAINLY NIGHT OF STATES
INCLUDE OREGON AND WASHINGTON
AND EVEN THE BRITISH COLUMBIA
ARE OF A TALKING TO THE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
SO THIS YEAR OF THREE DIFFERENT
PIECES ALL THE FEDERAL
LEGISLATION HOUSE BEING
INTRODUCED. TO PLACE TO CALL THE
WHOLE COUNTRY ON DAYLIGHT SAVING
TIME YOUR WRONG OR GIFT IS STATE
THE DISCRETION TO CHOOSE
STANDARD TIME OR DAYLIGHT SAVING
TIME.
AND A LAST YEAR DESPITE YOU PASS
A BILL TO ALLOW THE VOTERS TO
RECONSIDER THIS PRACTICE OSTRICH
FROM BACK IN FORCE.
AND THE VOTER HAS SPOKEN WITH
SOME MORE THAN 60% APPROVAL RATE.
WHAT WAS THIS BILL CALIFORNIA
WILL CONTINUE TO LEAD THE WAY
AND I'M RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL?
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU MISTER
OBERNOLTE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I RISE IS A PROUD TO
AUTHOR OF AB -- SEVEN IN
ADDITION TO ALL OF THE OTHER
BENEFITS THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
MENTIONED -- I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE GOOD THAT THIS WILL DO AND
HELPING CALIFORNIA MEET IT'S
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS I'M SURE
EVERYONE IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
DARKER.
WHICH SAYS THAT CALIFORNIA OVER
GENERATES IN RENEWABLES IN THE
DAYTIME WHEN THE WIND IS BLOWING
THE SUN IS SHINING WE UNDER
GENERATE AT NIGHT THIS WILL
SHIFT ENERGY CONSUMPTION INTO
THOSE EVENING HOURS.
AND BY A LOT OF ESTIMATES SAVE
CALIFORNIA OVER THREE THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS OF ELECTRICITY EVERY
DAY THIS WOULD BE HELP US REACH
OUR CLEAN ENERGY GOALS WOULD BE
GOOD FOR CALIFORNIA.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE MISS
GONZALEZ YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER -- QUITE
HONESTLY I'M JUST RISING ON THIS
MATTER IS A MOM I HAVE TO SAY
AND THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE YOUNG
CHILDREN SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN
KNOW THAT EVERY YEAR IN THE
SPRING TIME RIGHT WHEN WE'RE
PREPARING -- FOR TESTS AND IN
MANDATORY STANDARDIZED TESTS --
WE'RE TRYING TO SHAKE THE SLEEP
OUT OF KIDS EYES -- FOR OFTEN
LONGER THAN A WEEK OR TWO AS
THEY ADJUST TO THE LOSS OF AN
HOUR IT'S TIME WE JUST
STANDARDIZE THIS AND AND MOVE
FORWARD WITH A VERY SENSIBLE
PROPOSAL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GONZALES SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE WRONG.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE.
ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES SIXTY
TWO NO ZERO ON THE BILL AYE
SIXTY TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
AND WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SIX AB ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SOMETHING MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY
DO RECYCLING.
MISS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
OPEN ON THIS MATTER.
YES LAST YEAR REQUESTED A STATE
AUDIT OF THE MATTERS RECYCLING
COUNCIL TO TERMINA THAT THE
BEING COLLECTED ON MATTRESSES
WAS THAT IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
LAW AND HOW AND WHERE HE WAS YOU
SEEN THAT BINDING TO REACH.
I CALIFORNIA'S MATCHES EXACTLY
GOALS THE AUDIT REPORT
HIGHLIGHTED A NUMBER OF THE
ISSUES THAT NEEDED TO BE
ADDRESSED.
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT -- THOSE ISSUES IN THE
AUDIT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING A FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
SEVEN AB NINE FORTY THREE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE NINE FORTY THREE
WITH THE MEMONS BY SOMETHING
MEMBER DAVID CHIU.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES
MINUTES AT THE DESK WOULD STRIKE
A REFERENCE TO GENERAL PORTION
MEANT.
IN THE BILL CLARIFY THAT FUNDING
FOR EMERGENCY GRANTS COME FROM
THE STUDENT EQUITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT PROGRAM AND AT CO
AUTHORS ASK YOUR SUPPORT AND FOR
THE BILL TO BE SENT OUT TO PRINT.
PLACE BACK ON FILE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU SEEING AND
HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE A
VOICE VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AMENDMENTS ARE ADOPTED ME
OUT TO PRINT IN BACK TO FILE.
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX HUNDRED THE
CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX HUNDRED BY
SOMETHING MEMBER KANSEN CHU AND
ACTUALLY IN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MR CHIU YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER TIME AND MEMBERS I RISE
2% AB.
SIX HUNDRED WHICH CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE IN CURRENT LAW TO
PREVENTING CITIES FOR GOOD FORM
DOING WHAT WE CALL THE SELECTIVE
ANNEXATION PRACTICE.
A THIS BILL PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY.
AND WAS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHOOSE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THE VOTES AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS ONE THIS MEASURE
PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIX SIX
SIX AB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE
CLERK WILL READ SOMETHING ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GALLAGHER AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY BUSINESS.
TOGETHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT WILL HELP PROTECT MINERS
FROM -- BY REQUIRING SOCIAL
MEDIA PROVIDERS PROVIDE PARENTAL
CONSENT BEFORE ALLOWING MINORS
UNDER THE AGE OF THIRTEEN TO
CREATE SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS --
MINERS HAVE EXPERIENCE PROLIFIC
AMOUNTS OF ONLINE HARASSMENT
BULLYING AND PREDATORY TARGETING
OF MINORS.
ACCORDING TO RECENT POLLING
APPROX ME 59% OF MINORS AGED
THIRTEEN TO SEVENTEEN HAVE
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED ABUSE OF
ONLINE BEHAVIORS AND 13%.
HAVING HAVE RECEIVED UNWANTED
SEXUAL SOLICITATIONS AT THIS
BILL RECEIVE NO NO VOTES AND
RECENT AMENDMENTS TAKEN IN THE
PRIVACY AND PART -- CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS COMMITTEE REMOVED
MOVED OPPOSITION IN NEUTRAL ASK
FOR YOUR EITHER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GALLAGHER
MISTER LOW YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SPEAKER MEMBERS AND FORTUNE I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE.
AS PRESENTED YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT MEMBERS OF THE LGBT
COMMUNITY AND OTHERS.
USE MAY SEEK OUT OUTLETS TO FIND
INFORMATION ABOUT THEMSELVES
THIS POTENTIALLY COULD PUT OUR
LGBT YOUTH AT HARM SHOULD A
PARENT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
BE REQUIRED OF ON PARENTAL
CONSENT WE ALSO KNOW THAT IN
PRACTICE THERE ARE NUMBER OF
YOUNG PEOPLE THAT COULD GO
ONLINE AND PROVIDE FICTITIOUS
DATE OF BIRTH ON THESE PLATFORMS
AS IT CURRENTLY IS IN EXISTENCE.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY THE
TREVOR PROJECT HAS.
REGISTERED OPPOSITION AS WELL AS
THE INTERNET SO STATION CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE TECHNET ALIKE SO
RESPECTFULLY UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATIVE INTENT ON PROTECTING
OUR CHILDREN BUT AGAIN.
I THINK THAT THERE CAN BE SOME
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WITH
RESPECT TO MEMBERS OF THE LGB
COMMUNITY AND OTHERWISE IN
ACCESSING BASIC INFORMATION.
THANK YOU MISTER LOWE SEEING IN
HERE.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS MATTER THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I RISE IN SUPPORT AS A CO AUTHOR
THIS MEASURE TO ASK YOU TO
CONSIDER THE FOLLOWING -- ANGLE
WITH RESPECT TO THIS THIS ISSUE --
MANAGER FIRST NOTE LOOK AT AS A
PARENT OF FOUR AND SOMEBODY
WHO'S ABOUT TO HAVE.
AN EIGHT YEAR TO I WILL HAVE
THREE TEENAGERS IN MY HOUSEHOLD --
SO IN ADDITION TO YOUR PRAYERS I
APPRECIATE.
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THIS THIS
ARGUMENT -- THE INTENT OF THIS
BILLS TO GIVE PARENTS A LITTLE
MORE CONTROL AND THE AMERICAN
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION
REPORTS THAT 70% 70% OF OUR KIDS.
REPORT THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
BULLIED OR CYBER BULLIED ONLINE.
AS AN ATTORNEY I'VE WORKED ON
CASES WHERE KIDS WERE BULLIED
OVER SNAPCHAT AND THEIR PARENTS
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THEY EVEN HAD
AN ACCOUNT.
THEY WERE BULLIED SO BAD THAT
THEY HAD TO LEAVE A SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND GO TO ANOTHER
SCHOOL I MEAN THIS IS REAL IT'S
GOING ON IT'S AFFECTING ALL OF
OUR CHILDREN.
SO WHAT CAN WE DO ABOUT IT I
SUBMIT TO YOU THAT VOTING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. TO GIVE
PARENTS A LITTLE MORE CONTROL.
OVER WHAT'S GOING ON THERE
HOUSEHOLDS WHAT THEIR KIDS ARE
DOING THIS DOESN'T PREVENT ANY
MINOR FROM HAVING AN ACCOUNT.
IT SIMPLY SAYS PARENTS NEED TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION WITH THEIR
KIDS.
AND IT ONLY APPLIES TO KIDS --
THIRTEEN AND UNDER BEFORE THEY
SIGN UP FOR SNAPCHAT OR FACEBOOK
OR INSTAGRAM OR WHATEVER NEW
THING COMES OUT NEXT YEAR.
AND SUBJECT THEMSELVES POSSIBLY
TO THE TO CYBER BALLING THAT'S
GOING ON EVERY DAY.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES -- I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I BOTH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
MISTER GLORIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
ON THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I JUST
RISE TO A ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM CAMPBELL WITH
A TREMENDOUS RESPECT FOR OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM ORACLE TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES OF
THE SITUATION AND ASK MEMBERS TO
PUT YOURSELF.
IN MY COLLEAGUE AND I SHOES YOU
CAN IMAGINE THERE WAS A TIME
WHEN WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
DIRECTLY TO ADDRESS WHO AND WHAT
WE ARE TO OUR PARENTS.
I'M NOT BECOMES EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT CONVERSATIONS ONES
THAT WOULD BE MANDATED UNDER
THIS LAW.
I UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO KEEP
OUR KIDS SAFE BUT YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT DOESN'T WORK IS ONE SIZE
DOES NOT FIT ALL AND THERE'S A
SITUATION AND OUR CHILDREN THAT
ARE TODAY ALL THESE YEARS LATER.
ALL THESE YEARS LATER THIS IS
STILL A PARTICULAR PROBLEM SO
I'D ASK YOU TO BE THOUGHTFUL
WITH YOUR VOTES TODAY I
RECOGNIZE THE THE WHEEL -- WORDS
OF CAUTION FROM QUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND THE TREVOR
PROJECT WE KNOW THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE -- ARE OFTEN -- PREYED
UPON ONLINE BUT IT'S ALSO TRUE
THE ONLINE MAY BE THE ONLY
ACCESS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE A
TWO EIGHT IMPORTANT INFORMATION
THE ABILITY TO CONNECT WITH
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIKE THEM AND
GIVE THEM A SAFE SPACE TO
OPERATE IN THE WORLD.
I ASK YOU THINK VERY LONG AND
HARD ABOUT YOUR VOTE TODAY AND
RECOGNIZE THAT MAYBE THERE'S
NEEDS FOR MORE TIME TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE CHILDREN THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
HAVE A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN BE
THEMSELVES WITHOUT DISCLOSING
WHO THEY ARE TO THEIR PARENTS
BEFORE THEY ARE READY IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT THING TO MEMBERS
BILLS VIEW COMMUNITY ASK YOU
THINK ABOUT THIS VOTE.
AFTER THIS MORNING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MADAM SIR CAN I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION OF THE OTHER
WHICH YOU COULD USE ANSWER NOW
YOU COULD USE ANSWERING YOUR
CLOTHES.
IT IS ACTION.
HOW CAN YOU VERIFY THAT THE
PARENT HAS ACTUALLY GIVEN
CONSENT -- AND I THINK I
MENTIONED THIS IN COMMITTEE IT
TOOK ALL OF THREE MINUTES FOR MY
BROTHER AND I WHEN WE WERE YOUNG
TO FIGURE OUT THE CODE THAT MY
DAD PUT ON THE TV.
SO THAT WE COULD WATCH MOVIES
THAT WERE P. G. THIRTEEN OR
HIGHER -- AND AND SO KIDS ARE
PRETTY CLEVER OF BEING ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW.
TO GET AROUND DIFFERENT PARENTAL
CONSENT SO UNLESS YOU'RE GOING
TO ASK THE PARENT TO PROVIDE.
PICTURE ID OR I I'M JUST CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW YOU ENVISION.
THESE PLATFORMS TO VERIFY THAT
THE PARENTS ARE ACTUALLY GIVING
THAT CONSENT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT PIECE --
AND THEN THE CONSIDERATION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DO GIVEN THE TYPE OF
INFORMATION THAT WE'RE ASKING
THESE PLATFORMS AND NOW COLLECT.
AND STORE AND YOU KNOW THAT CAN
BE HACKED IN THAT INFORMATION
CAN BE COMPROMISED AT SOME POINT
TIME SO AT SOME POINT TIME YOU
COULD JUST ANSWER -- HOW THAT IS
GOING TO WORK ON APPRECIATE IT?
THANK YOU MISTER CALDERON SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
[inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER.
YOU WHILE YOU MAY CLOSE.
YEAH MANAGE FIGURE IF I COULD
JUST CLOSE -- COUPLE THINGS ARE
BROUGHT UP YOU KNOW ONE ONE
THING I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT TO SEE
JUST TWO STORIES -- QUICK
STORIES THEY KIND OF WERE A
MOTIVATION FOR ME ONE I HEARD
FROM A SCHOOL RESOURCE OFFICER
IN RED BLUFF -- WHO EVERY DAY IS
INTERACTING WITH KIDS ON CAMPUS --
AND HE SAID YOU KNOW SHE TOLD
THIS WHOLE GROUP OF PEOPLE SHE
GOES YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GET WHEN
OUR KIDS TURNED SIXTEEN AGAIN
THE KEYS IN THE CAR.
AND THEY HAVE FREE REIGN TO GO
AROUND THE REGION.
IN THEIR AND THEIR CAR RIGHT.
ANDSHE GOES BUT WE GIVE OUR
KIDS A PHONE.
AND WE GIVE THEM ACCESS TO THE
ENTIRE WORLD.
AND SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED INCH AND HER POINT WAS HEY
JUST LIKE WHEN WE GET THE KIDS
THE KEYS THE CAR WE GIVE THEM
INSTRUCTION WE WORK WITH THEM WE
TRY AND MAKE SURE THEY CAN BE
SAFE.
WE NEED TO DO THE SAME THING
WITH SOCIAL MEDIA BECAUSE
THEY'RE EXPOSED TO A WHOLE
BROADER RANGE IN THERE.
AND THOUGH I DEFINITELY
UNDERSTAND THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
RAISED -- HERE ON THIS FLOOR.
OVERWHELMINGLY WHAT KIDS ARE
EXPERIENCING A CYBER BULLYING WE
HAVE SEXUAL PREDATORS THAT ARE
THAT ARE GOING ONLINE AND TRYING
TO LURE KIDS WE HAVE HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS THAT ARE USING THIS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ENCOURAGE
THIS CONVERSATION BETWEEN KIDS.
AND THEIR PARENTS.
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A MORE
PERSONAL STORY I TALKED TO MY
OWN DAUGHTER AS A HEY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE PLAYING THESE GAMES.
THEY EVER ASK YOUR AGE -- YEAH
ALL THE TIME.
I SAY WELL WHAT DO YOU SAY --
OTTOMAN.
TWENTY FOUR YEAH AND AND FOR SO
THAT WAS A WAKE UP MOMENT FOR ME
LIKE HEY YOU KNOW I I NEED TO DO
THIS.
MYSELF THIS LEGISLATION
ENCOURAGES THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION.
AND AS FAR AS WHAT WILL THE WHAT
WHAT CAN THE TECH COMPANIES DO
TO ADDRESS THIS THEY ALREADY ARE.
AND MANY KIDS LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
WOULD JUL WHO SELLS YOU KNOW
VAPING.
PRODUCTS ONLINE THEY HAVE TO
VERIFY.
THE PEOPLE ARE OF IT OF AGE TO
HAVE.
THAT -- INTO TO BUY THAT PRODUCT.
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES CAN
CERTAINLY DO THE SAME THING AND
HELP VERIFY THAT A CHILD IS OF
AGE THAT THERE IS PARENTAL.
CONSENT HERE AND SO LOOK I THINK
THE OVERWHELMING.
THERE ARE CERTAINLY RESOURCES
OUT THERE THEY CAN HELP -- THEY
CAN HELP ALL OF ALL PEOPLE YOU
KNOW -- SOCIAL MEDIA IS NOT THE
ONLY OUTLET. FOR PEOPLE GO I I
WOULD HOPE THAT SOCIAL MEDIA.
IS NOT THE ONLY OUTLET FOR OUR
USE THIS IS REALLY ABOUT.
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION WITH OUR WITH OUR
CHILDREN THAT WE HELP BETTER
PROTECT.
MINERS FROM THE VERY ABUSIVE
PRACTICES THAT WE KNOW ARE
HAPPENING ONLINE SO I WOULD I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU. TO HELP
SUPPORT THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK ON IT WE DID AMENDED TO
THIRTEEN YEARS OLD.
WHICH IS CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL
LAW AND THAT DID NEUTRALIZE ALL
OPPOSITION -- SO THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL -- THE
OPPOSITION WAS REGISTERED IN
COMMITTEE MOVED TO NEUTRAL UPON
THAT AMENDMENT SO I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE
.
MR GALLERY IS A CALL WE ARE
READY TO LIFT THE CALL AND FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY TWO AB ONE SIXTY
TO THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ON MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
MISTER CARLOS MOVING THE CAR.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
EIGHT AB TEN THIRTY FIVE THE
CLERK WILL READ.
AS A LEGAL TEN THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES AND
ACTUALLY THE INFORMATION PRIVACY
MR MAYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS MATTER THE MINUTE
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS -- TODAY I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BUILT -- TEN THIRTY FIVE WHICH
SEEKS TO STRENGTHEN NOTIFICATION
CROP REQUIREMENTS IN THE EVENT
OF DATA BREACHES.
AND A PERSONAL INFORMATION OF
CALIFORNIANS.
AS TECHNOLOGY CONTINUES TO
FIRST CENTURY WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR LAWS ADJUST TO
HOLD BAD ACTORS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
PLAYING FAST AND LOOSE WITH
THEIR CONSTITUENTS PERSONAL DATA.
A NEW STORIES FROM INDUSTRY ARE
BONDED WITH ERRORS AND FAILURE
TO SELF REGULATE.
THIS MEASURES SEEK TO IMPLEMENT
A HARD CAP AT FORTY FIVE DAYS
UNLESS THE GYM IT NEEDS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
TIME TO TRACK DOWN THE
PERPETRATOR.
I DO PLEDGE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO IMPROVE OUR
DATA BREACH LAWS IN A MANNER
THAT HOLDS BUSINESSES
ACCOUNTABLE BUT ALSO PROVIDE
CLARITY RELIEF WHEN THEY'RE
ACTING PRUDENTLY.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAY IS SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
LONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRED
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE EYES SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO THIS MEASURE PASSES
.
WE'RE GONNA FILE ITEM IGHTY
FIVE AB FIFTEEN TEN THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES AND OTHERS
AND ACTUALLY BEING SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT.
REYES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN ON
THIS MATTER.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I PRESENT AB.
FIFTEEN TEN THE BILL THAT
REVIVES ANY CLAIMS FOR DAMAGES
ARISING OUT OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT
OR THEIR SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
COMMITTED BY BY A POSITION AT A
STUDENT HEALTH CENTER.
EVEN THOUGH THE CLAIM MAY HAVE
BE ON TIME BARRED BECAUSE OF THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS.
THIS BILL RESPONSE TO ALMOST
THREE DECADES OF SEXUAL
EXPLOITATION AND ASSAULT OF OVER
FOURTEEN THOUSAND YOUNG WOMEN.
AT U. S. C..
EARLIER THIS YEAR I WAS SHOCKED
TO FIND OUT THAT FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS U. ARE SEIZE
LONGTIME GYNECOLOGIST R TYNDALL.
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED HIS PATIENTS
AND OFTEN TARGETED WOMEN OF
COLOR AND IMMIGRANT WOMEN WITH
HIS WORST BEHAVIOR.
THIS BILL WHAT IT WILL EXTEND
THE STATURE LIMITATIONS FOR ONE
YEAR AND ALLOW SURVIVORS TO
FATHER CASES IN COURT IF THEY SO
CHOOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTRESS.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESIRED
[inaudible]
DEVELOP.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTE AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE KNOWS HERE THIS MEASURE
PASSES
.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA AND
ACTUALLY THE REDEVELOPMENT.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE.
I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AS ONLY ABLE TO FIFTY THREE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TEN FORTY THREE I SEVENTY FOUR
NO ZERO AS A LEGAL FOURTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO IS ILLEGAL SIX TWENTY THREE
I SEVENTY FOUR NEW ZERO IS
ILLEGAL SIX SEVENTY NINE I
SEVENTY FOUR NEW. ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL SIX NINETY EIGHT I SEVENTY
FOUR NEW ZERO IS ON THE BILL
SEVEN THIRTY I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO IS ONLY WILL SEVENTEEN
FIFTY TWO I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
ITS LOCAL.
SEVENTEEN TWENTY THREE I SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO AS LEGAL SEVENTEEN
FORTY FIVE HI SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN OH
THREE WITH URGENCY.
I SEVENTY FOUR KNOWS YOU'RE ON
THE URGENCY AND I SEVENTY FOUR
NEWS HERE ON THE BILL.
SOME PEOPLE EIGHTEEN TWELVE I
SEVENTY FOUR NEW ZERO AS AN ABLE
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN I SEVENTY FOUR
KNOWS THEIR OWN ASSEMBLY WILL
FORTY NINE I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO ISRAEL ONE FORTY THREE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO A SOMETHING
LITTLE.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE I SEVENTY FOUR
NEWS ZERO IS UNABLE TO THIRTY
THREE I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO
IT'S ONLY LETS YOU NINETY FIVE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO AS LEGAL
FIVE NINETY THREE FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO SOMETHING WILL FIVE
NINETY SIX I SEVENTY FOUR NO.
ZERO IS UNABLE SIX FORTY FOUR I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO IT'S UNABLE
SIX FIFTY THREE I SEVENTY FOUR
NO ZERO A SINGLE SIX SEVENTY TWO
I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO CYNICAL
SEVEN OH THREE I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO AS ONLY WILL IT -- TO YOU I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO IT'S ONLY
LATER SIX I SEVENTY FOUR NEWS
ZERO AS ONLY LATER NINE I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO AS LEGAL
EIGHT FIFTEEN I. SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY NINETEEN I SEVENTY
FOUR NO. ZERO EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO AS ONLY
LATE SOME BEFORE I SEVENTY FOUR
NO ZERO SOMETHING LIKE NINETY
FOUR I SEVENTY FOUR NEWS ZERO A
SINGLE TEN ON NINE I SEVENTY
FOUR NO.
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TEN SEVENTEEN I
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO UNTIL TEN
THIRTY TWO I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO A SINGLE EVENT TWENTY SEVEN
I SEVENTY FOUR NEWS ZERO SOME
PEOPLE LIVE IN FIFTY FIVE
SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
THIRTEEN FIFTY FIVE I SEVENTY
FOUR NO.
ZERO AS A LITTLE FORTINO FOR I
SEVENTY FOUR NEWS ZERO SOME
PEOPLE FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO I
SEVENTY FOUR NEW ZERO AS LITTLE
FOURTEEN SIXTY SEVEN I SEVENTY
FOUR NEWS ZERO SOME
PEOPLE
FOURTEEN SEVENTY FIVE I SEVENTY
FOUR SOME PEOPLE.
FIFTEEN THIRTY TWO I SEVENTY
FOUR NOCERA'S UNABLE FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOUR I SEVENTY FOUR NO
ZERO IT'S ONLY A FIFTEEN NINETY
ONE I SEVENTY FOUR NO ZERO AS
LEGAL SIXTEEN SIXTY TI SEVENTY
FOUR NO ZERO CYNICAL SIXTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN I SEVENTY FOUR NO.
ZERO LEVEL.
TEN SEVENTY NINE ZERO MR KILEY
IS READY TO LIFT THE CALL ON
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY TWO AB ONE
SIXTY TO THE CLERK WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTED DESERVE A
ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE
TO VOTE -- MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TELEVOTE.
I THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS.
FIFTEEN THE MEASURE FAILS.
MR KILEY NOTICES RECONSIDERATION
WE ARE READY TO LIFT THE CALL
AND FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY SIX AB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL POST.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESERVE A
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE IN
TALLY THE VOTES.
AYE AYES TWENTY FIVE NEWS.
ELEVEN THIS MEASURE FAILS.
MR GALLAGHER SPEAKER I NOTICED
RECONSIDERATION SIR GALLAGHER
NOTICES RECONSIDERATION.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO WISH MISTER GLORIA
A VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MAY TENTH NO
FLOOR SESSION AND NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY MAY THIRTEENTH
FLOOR SESSION AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR
.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR WE ARE MOVING TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY
.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS ARE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MISS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR DESK FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
WE'RE HAVING WE'RE ASKING THEM
TO LEAVE THE CHAMBER.
THIS GARCIA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN IN MEMORY THANK
YOU ARE I SEE THEY TO JOIN IN
THE MEMORY OF MONTEBELLO POLICE
OFFICER CANON THAT SINGER.
HE WAS BORN IN ANCHORAGE ALASKA
AND RACE IN LAWTON OKLAHOMA.
CAN AT THE TIME WAS SWORN IN AS
THE MONTEBELLO POLICE OFFICER ON
JANUARY TWENTY THIRD.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN CANADA
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE HIS FATHER
HIS MOTHER SISTER Là INTO
RESCUE DOG THAT HE AND HIS WIFE
ADORED.
ALTHOUGH THEY DID NOT HAVE
CHILDREN MONTEBELLO POLICE CHIEF
RECALL CAN IT SAYING ATIS RAIN
IN.
THOSE ARE MY KIDS ARE IN
REFERENCE TO THEIR RESCUE DOGS.
HE WAS A CORRECTIONAL OFFICER IN
OKLAHOMA FOR ELEVEN YEARS.
HE AND HIS WIFE MOVED TO
CALIFORNIA IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN TO BE CLOSER TO HIS
WIFE'S SISTER.
AS COMMANDER ALL CAN IT SAID HIS
LIFELONG DREAM WAS TO BE A
POLICE OFFICER.
AND AFTER WORKING IN CORRECTIONS
FOR ELEVEN YEARS HE WAS LOOKING
FORWARD TO BEING ON THE STREETS.
IF AS HE PUT IT HE COULD MAKE IT
THROUGH THE ACADEMY SINCE HE WAS
A LITTLE OLDER.
THAN MOST HE WAS FORTY IN THE
CAT IMIA AND TURN FORTY ONE JUST
A FEW WEEKS AGO.
CAN IT WITH VOTED BY HIS PEERS
THE REAL HAN THE POLICE ACADEMY
AS THE MOST INSPIRATIONAL
RECRUIT.
OFFICER KENNETH IN SINGER WAS
FOUND THE SEIZE ON APRIL TWENTY
FIRST.
MEMBERS WE CAN NEVER PREPARE OR
UNDERSTAND WHY SOMEONE WITH SUCH
POTENTIAL LEAVE US SO SOON.
BUT WE CAN'T REMEMBER CASPER'S
HUMANITY INSPIRATION AND IS
THERE TO SERVE.
PLEASE KEEP THE IN THING OUR
FAMILY CAN IT'S WIFE HEATHER HIS
SISTER Là MAN THAT AND IS
MONTEBELLO COLLEAGUES AND FAMILY
IN YOUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA PLEASE
BRING THE NAME TO THE DESK TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL --
REQUEST TO JOURNEY MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS AND RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISS RIVAS MOVES IN MISTER
CUNNINGHAM SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY MAY THIRTEENTH AT ONE PM
.
YOU JUST NOW.
JUST A NOW [inaudible]
HEY.
WENDY CARILLO A. B. SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT NO HI.
BOOK CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO AS LEGAL SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT KNOWS I BUT CHANGE
CUNNINGHAM A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT NO TWO I THE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AS A
LABEL ELEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT NO
TÁI -- CHANGE LACKEY SB SIX
HUNDRED NOTIFY.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LACKEY ASSEMBLY BILL SIX HUNDRED
NO TIE.
BEAU CHANGE KAMLAGER-DOVE.
AB FOUR THIRTY THREE I TO KNOW.
THE CHANGE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE AS A LEGAL FOR
THIRTY THREE I TO KNOW.
I HAVE I HAVE TO DO [inaudible]
YEAH YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
OR ALL [inaudible]
THAT